oh I will try to speak slowly sometimes
I speak a little bit fast when I get
excited and this is something is the
topic that it is very exciting to me but
maybe like somebody could somebody like
flag me down if I'm starting to talk to
you fast and nobody is understanding
what I'm saying
and I'll also try to enunciate although
we are not known for that where I come
from so without further ado welcome to
my talk and good morning for another 15
minutes so my talk is called yellow
brick it's about a new Python package
that I've been working on for the last
year and a half it's open source feel
free to look it up while I'm talking
we're on github and we have a website
which is Sai kit - YB dot o-r-g I
actually have stickers for everyone so I
will pass out stickers that have that
URL maybe here you pass them back that
way
you know what the how to get there
and I have more that I can give out
later I'm also doing a book signing
right after lunch for a book that is
almost halfway done but apparently they
print those and let you sign copies at
events like this so if you want to talk
to me come tat then and you might I
think in a free galley copy of that book
along with my signature which is worth
plenty I'm sure
ok so yellow brick a little bit about me
I am from America I live in Washington
DC here's my contact information I've
worked in a lot of different contexts so
I've worked in academia
do you have a PhD if not in machine
learning
as just in case you are wondering but as
I was a I did academic research I worked
for the American government for a while
and now I work in the private sector and
I have to teach at Georgetown University
I teach machine learning so but kind of
across all of these things there's this
sort of trend with machine learning and
particularly with I'm seeing a lot of
people working on natural language
processing it seems like that has been a
real hit topic at this conference which
I think is really fascinating so
originally though in order to do machine
learning or talk about machine learning
were you know work in the machine
learning space you lived in an ivory
tower and you went to school for many
many years to study machine learning and
probably you went to school for many
many years to study a certain set of
machine learning models a certain model
family and you got very good at tuning
that model family and you work you know
you worked very hard on a very narrow
narrowly focused area and those were the
only people who were doing machine
learning for a long long time and then
everything changed in about 2010 so in
2010 an RIA started supporting
scikit-learn it became a public
open-source package
people started contributing fast and
scikit-learn started to grow really
really really fast and everything
changed
right so all of a sudden all you had to
know to do machine learning with pythons
and we all note like we all know enough
Python to you scikit-learn right
everybody in here has messed around with
it I'm just going to assume and if you
haven't like you really could do you
know if you are if you're like oh I
could never do machine learning like
literally like 20 minutes after having
installed scikit-learn and finding some
you know data set on the you know the
berkeley webpage they have a bunch of
cached you know data sets that you can
play with the machine
repository you can be doing machine
learning so part of what is sort of so
magical about scikit-learn is the API
and what and I think that you know
there's a lot that's going for
scikit-learn it has a lot of models it
has a lot of things that aren't models
it has you know a bunch of very useful
transformers it has vectorizer x' it has
pipelines which are incredibly useful
for production code but the I think the
real magic about what makes scikit-learn
special and when people ask me why do
you do machine learning in Python it's
really the scikit-learn API that's the
reason it's because you can have your
data formatted in a certain way and you
can run it through as many models as you
like without having to continue to
transform the model to fit or the data
to fit each kind of model that didn't
exist before
and so now it's just an optimization
problem right so for for supervised
learning problems at least you know the
target and so you can score your model
and you know how well it's performing
and so you throw the data at all of the
different classifiers and you score them
and whichever one does best is the
winner right and it's as easy as that
it's an optimization problem you can
automate that and in fact increasingly
people are automating that and there's a
lot of tools out there and I get emails
being all the time because it says
machine learning on my LinkedIn profile
and so I get all of these like vultures
who are selling like automated machine
learning tools to me all the time and
they say you know it takes the guesswork
out of machine learn and you don't even
have to think you know in order to do it
and when I kind this is kind of how I
feel like you know I think that those
attempts to automate the optimization
problem are really not sort of taking
into account how big the search space
really is in practice you know so for a
very you know tightly constrained hyper
parameter space those optimization tools
might work grid search does work if you
already know
you know the range for your hyper
parameters if you know alpha is probably
somewhere between here and here you know
you can you can do a grid search and
it'll compute after you know a day or
two or three or however you know however
long but as that hyper parameter space
gets larger as you're dealing with
multiple hyper parameters it really is
feels like blind search and for people
who are just getting into machine
learning who don't know what
hyperparameters are and if you're using
a model that you've never studied you
don't know what the - you just use the
defaults I could learn hyper parameters
which are actually very good in general
over the average but as you start to
tune things and you you know you want to
get a little bit of gain uh you know
playing with those hyper parameters are
really where the games come from and if
you don't know them it's really like
blind search and that's probably not
very satisfying to you either right so
you know even if you feel sort of like a
wizard when you're using scikit-learn
you know using a model that you don't
really understand can sometimes feel not
so good so what I propose to you is that
the solution to this is visual steering
and so this is a combination of human
intuition and computation power and the
scikit-learn api and you know we're
basically going to integrate
visualization into our machine learning
processes so that we can quickly
visualize models see how they're
performing understand which ones are
performing best and why and then move
along with our predictions right so you
can look at a picture like this in a
second and see which model is the best
right so that's what yellow brick is
yellow brick is a Python library it's
open source it's on github it extends
the scikit-learn api and i'll talk about
that a little bit more at the end of
this talk because I'm hoping that there
are people in here who might want to be
contributors I know that anybody who's
in this session is missing the session
on contributing to open source for the
first time so if
you were torn I would be happy to talk
to you about contributing to open source
for the first time yellow brick is the
first time that I've managed an
open-source project and I if a humbling
experience and I would be delighted to
talk to any of you about that later but
essentially it's designed to enhance the
model selection process and it provides
tools sort of in three different areas
for feature visualization for model
Diagnostics and for visual steering and
I'm going to talk about that kind of
that's what the presentation really is
about those three kind of things and I
want to say up front because I do get
this question a lot this is not a
replacement for other visualization
libraries so I'm not trying to beat
Seabourn or you know elbow out bouquet
you know this is supposed to augment the
Python visualization landscape and and
all of the all of these features are
built in pure Python so it's pure MATLAB
which I will talk about a little bit
more is a bit of a challenge because map
pot live is amazing but it's kind of
it's designed to be sort of procedural
so it's hard to make it object-oriented
like scikit-learn api if you're used to
the scikit-learn estimator interface
you're used to you know something kind
of like this flow right you you import
the estimator you instantiate it you fit
the data and then you call predict right
so I told you it's magic right you can
do you can do machine learning and not
know anything about what you're doing as
four lines of code so the yellow-brick
visualizer interface kind of fits in
something like this where you import
your scikit-learn model you import your
your visualizers you instantiate the
visualizer you call fit on the
visualizer that calls fit on the model
and you can score it and you poop it
I'll talk about the the interface a
little bit more we need to have a
different method so that the methods
don't confuse people across matplotlib
and scikit-learn and yellow brick so our
kind of
mein render method is called poof it
started out as a joke and you know how
those things go okay so I want to talk
first a little bit about what we offer
in terms of feature selection and
feature engineering so the beginning of
the machine learning process usually
begins not with what's the coolest model
like what's the flavor of the month in
terms of the algorithm and I'm going to
use it actually starts with which
features do I use which features are
predictive and so here's an example
we've got a data set with room occupancy
data so we've got you know you kind of
picturing tabular data here the rows are
instances of rooms and the columns are
features or attributes about those rooms
how much humidity there is in the room
how much co2 output there is how much
light there is and the target is whether
or not the room is occupied if it's
occupied it's a 1 if it's not occupied
at 2-0 let's say so given that data
which of those features is most
predictive and how hard is it going to
be to distinguish unoccupied from
occupied rooms using the features that
we have these are kind of the questions
that you that you asked at the beginning
of a machine learning problem so you can
use a radial visualization like this
some some of you probably have seen this
already it's available in pandas I think
you can do rad viz and pandas you can
also do it in yellow brick and without
having to import pandas if you're an
umpire kind of person so you can use a
radial visualization like this to
quickly answer those two questions so we
can clearly see that there there are
some features that are more predictive a
radial visualization is a you know if
you plot the features along a unit
circle and then you drop all of the
instances inside the circle and you let
the features pull the points according
to their their normalized value right so
we can see temperature is clearly
predictive here which you know you would
kind of expect right if there's a body
in the room it gets
as we all can feel right now and you
know the other question is you know we
want to do classification classification
is about separable 'ti how hard is it
going to be to separate the classes
based on the features we have and you've
got a clear visual visualization here of
blue dots and green dots and maybe it's
not linearly separable but we can see
that there is some separable ax T here
we're going to be able to do
classification we have a good feeling
about this right so yellow-brick offers
future visualizers like this so we
talked about radial visualization you
can also do this with parallel
coordinates or Andrews curves our
variation on parallel coordinates but
essentially what we're looking for here
is you know are the features predictive
which features are most predictive and
do we have good class separable 'ti and
we can look at pictures and quickly see
that right away and that's very powerful
so rank 2 D is another future visualizer
tool some of you may have seen things a
little bit like this called slum
scatterplot matrices so scatterplot
matrices you know basically like a big
version of this that show a lot more
detail you know it doesn't scale very
well to a lot of features so our
implementation of rank 2d is a little
bit more compact music heat map and
basically what you're looking for are
pairwise relationships between the
features right so we want to be able to
detect things like collinearity things
that might interfere with the modeling
process so these are things that are
very powerful for feature engineering so
we can see you know these kind of this
heat map shows us like clumps of
activities where you know there's a
strong relationship between features and
we want to take a look at that and see
this is the the credit default data set
which you would expect to see some
collinearity right so you know for
months months people carry debt months a
month and so if you have a lot of debt
last month and you had a lot of depth a
month before probably you know you're
not paying it down maybe as quickly as
you should be so you would expect to see
: Eric collinearity
main features so what sort of unique
though is that we have future
visualization feature visualizers for
text - and this is something that you
know this is very relevant to me since
I'm doing work in NLP and my features
are very different from the future is
that you know people who are doing
traditional machine learning or dealing
with for one text data is notoriously
extremely high dimensional which makes
it very difficult to visualize
especially with something like Python
but here are some tools that we have
that we've implemented in yellow bricks
and make it a little bit easier we've
got frequency distribution plots that's
also available in NLP kay our
implementation is just map pot labs you
don't have to have the NL TK overhead so
that shows you the most common tokens
from your corpus and you can actually do
a visualization of this before and after
stop words removal which is a really
good way to see how well as your stop
words removal working to identify
salient tokens we've got the tea Smith
plot the stochastic neighbor embedding a
plot which does a dimensionality
reduction and then projects into 2d
space and does the scatter plot so you
can start to visualize you know by class
suppose it like a dot if you're doing
document classification for instance you
can see by class you know how diffuse is
a certain topic versus another topic and
then in the bottom you can see visuals
part of speech tagging which is
available in yellow brick and this is
really useful to see how well your part
of speech tagger is using if you're used
to using and out-of-the-box part of
speech tagger and you're working with
text that's a little bit non-standard
part of speech tagging just depends on
on regular expressions right which
assumes that the text is regular and if
your text is a little bit irregular you
might want to sort of diagnose error by
doing a part of speech visualization to
see how well your part of speech tagger
is performing so another common question
is what is the right model to use and a
lot of times people will you know ask me
about this in
us you know why isn't the model I picked
predictive and one of the first things
that I ask is you know if they're doing
classification is do you have the class
and balance problems because that is
sort of notoriously a cause for
classification challenges and you can do
a really quick visualization in yellow
brick and rapidly see you know is class
imbalance interfering with my prediction
should I be thinking about a different
model that will be that will handle that
better like a you know a tree based
model for instance or do I need to use
something like stratified sampling or
getting more data or over sampling or
something like that
so yellow-brick offers a few options for
score visualizers for classification
we've got you know the classic rock off
if that's what you're used to this is a
you know a good way to sort of see you
know overall how your your classifier is
performing but you can also use yellow
brick to start diagnosing some of the
problems and so we see here we've got a
visual classification report heat map
and a visual confusion matrix those are
very helpful for identifying you know
not just overall accuracy with the f1
score but starting to get a feel for
places where your model is performing
better or worse and that's really
important you know because you know
false positives and false negatives kind
of have different implications this is
that sort of you know that kind of
classic problem of you know if the
question is poisonous mushroom or not
poisonous mushroom which side would you
rather err on you know and so sometimes
overall accuracy is not as relevant as a
particular you know precision or recall
score right and confusing matrix is
really helpful for seeing on a per class
basis where you're miss classifications
are happening most so if you're a
regression person and you are you may be
used to seeing prediction error
plots and residuals pots so you know
essentially these are doing the same
thing with a prediction error plot here
on the Left we've got the 45-degree line
which is sort of the theoretical perfect
model and you can see how well your
model is you're out your fitted model is
performing relative to that sort of
theoretical perfect in the residuals
plot it's that you know the zero is the
no error line and you can see how well
your your regressor is performing but
one thing that I find very helpful about
these visualizations in yellow-brick is
that it helps you quickly diagnose
problems like heteroscedasticity and so
we can see in both of these plots this
is the same data plotted two ways you
can see in in both of these plots that
the that the amount of variance changes
as we go along the axis so there's more
variance here than there is here you can
see the same thing here so that's called
heteroscedasticity that can interfere
with modeling and that's a very
important thing to be able to diagnose
early on okay so third category of
features that yellow brick offers are
for hyper parameter tuning and like I
said early on you know model selection
is good future engineering is a lot of
work and it's very important but the
magic of you know being a expert machine
learning practitioner is really in
learning how to do really good hyper
parameter tuning so we built some
features that help with this so what is
the right value of K in k-means
clustering is this my students ask me
this a lot and I would just make up a
number so how many clusters you see yeah
oh yeah so so it's hard right how do you
start how do you pick an initial value
of K there's rules of thumb for this you
know you pick a number and then you know
you see how well the clusters look and
then maybe you take a lower kaor a
higher k
and maybe partitive clustering is the
wrong choice for this data set but we
can't tell right from looking at this
picture but you actually can do hyper
parameter tuning for optimal k value
using silhouette scores silhouette
scores is something that is exposed
through the scikit-learn api with
k-means clustering and mini-batch
k-means also and so essentially he
doesn't come with the smiley and sad
faces I added those just to make sure
that's clear but I want to do to see
that you can kind of like once you're
once you learn how to see these plots or
once you learn how to you know
understand them you can start to see
like okay I picked the wrong K I can
tell I picked the wrong K because I've
got these sort of dense are these a
diffuse clusters and some dense clusters
this red line is the average
silhouettes core value and you know so
I'm doing okay but when I look at this I
say you know that maybe should be two
different clusters and that probably
should be at least two different
clusters and so I probably want to
increase my K and you can also use elbow
curves
has anybody seen elbow curves before so
elbow curves are all at least our
implementation in yellow brick is also
using silhouette scores to calculate the
elbow but essentially what you're what
you do is you pick a range of values for
K and you plot the silhouette scores for
each of those values and then you can
see if there's an elbow of that kind of
peak points is the optimal value of K
however if you get a plot that looks
kind of like this that tells you that
maybe there isn't a best value for K and
potentially this means that you should
be doing not partitive clustering that
may be that may be part of clustering is
not the clusters you're dealing with
maybe are not kind of uniformly dense
maybe they're not spherical and so it
sort of suggests maybe I should be using
like a hierarchical algorithm and it in
for a more kind of traditional problem I
get a question of you know which
regularizer should I use or should I use
regularization and so you can use
analysis plot in yellow-brick to see if
if regularization is even working at all
right so what we're doing here is we're
plotting the amount of error along
different alphas so as we increase the
Alpha so this is like l1 l2
regularization so lasso and Ridge and
then elastic net is the combination of
l1 and l2 so you can kind of plot the
amount of error in your model as your
alpha increases and if you see something
like this you should maybe wonder
whether or not regularization is really
the right choice because your error is
getting worse as you regularize more
right and it should be the other way
around right so we regularize so that
our model will generalize better and
this is not not working from this
picture and that's that's a helpful
thing to be able to visualize okay so
finally what I would like to try to
convince you of is not just to use
yellow brick but to consider
contributing to yellow brick what I
imagine is that and I've already seen
from all of the other talks that I've
been to over the last two days that
there are a lot of people doing machine
learning here there's a you know robust
machine learning community I imagine
that you have a lot of visualizations
that you're that you're using that kind
of help with this and I would love for
you to contribute so you know you're if
you're used to this I can learn API
you're used to estimators they have a
fit method and predict method
transformers have a transform method
they transform data and so visualizers
can be estimators or transformers and
they kind of have you know the base the
the abstract base class basically has
these three methods it has a draw method
it has a finalized method and it has the
poof method so draw is what creates
the plot the MATLAB put the pipe fly API
so it creates the plot finalized add
things like color labels and poof
renders the visualization so if you
would like to see more of what's
available I would encourage you to check
out our documentation the link to the
documentation is on the stickers and I
will pass out some more at psychic a -
YB dot underscore ARS RR g so you can
visit the documentation and we have a
lot of examples up there we have a
contributors guide and you know there's
you know installation instructions which
you can see here we actually just did a
version bump on Friday I'm a little bit
jet-lagged so I actually don't know what
day it is it's like 5:00 a.m. in America
so we did a version bump on Thursday if
America time so we're on version 0.40
which has all of the features that I
just showed you are available now we
have a few more I'm working on a
dendrogram visualizer for people who
realize that came in k-means isn't
working for them you switch to using a
dendrogram visualizer to visualize how
well your kilometer a glommit of
clustering model is working so I'm
working on that right now that will be
in the next version if you have an idea
I would love to hear it another thing
we're looking for is so people to use
the library and find bugs and submit bug
reports that would be amazing you know
submit an issue if you try it out and
you get an error let us know people to
contribute features I'm sure you have
interesting ideas please make
suggestions and we also are looking for
people to write blog posts so if you're
just getting into the community and
maybe you're not ready to contribute a
feature but you're sort of interested in
kind of starting to play a role in the
community we have a a blog the district
data labs blog it's read all over the
world
and we will publish you and I mean we'll
publish you even if you don't write
about yellow-brick but if you I would
love it but write a post about
yellow-brick and how you use it in a
youth case if you end up using it but
anyway so that's all I've got
again this is me my name is Rebecca and
you can follow me on Twitter all of my
basically all my social media things
github it's all Rebecca bill bro so I
try to be maximally discoverable so come
find me and come get a sticker and maybe
come to the book signing and try to get
a free galley copy of my book and thank
you very much for for coming
[Applause]
which way would you get to music to
being the boss so that that is such a
great question and that is you know that
was a hard choice the question is do we
envision integrating like JavaScript's
kind of DS maybe d3 or something like
that which would allow interactivity for
some of these I think that would
definitely make these visualizers better
it would be better to be able to have
like a toggle so like you toggle over
values of a certain hyper parameter and
watch you know the graphs change I think
that would be fantastic
I don't think that it will kind of work
with yellow brick but we have another
project called cultivar and so if you
want to talk about cultivars also on
github but it's basically a parallel
project that's meant to be kind of a
Django it's a Django application that
can have you know native JavaScript to
allow for for basically interactive
versions of these visualizers but yeah
that's an excellent question
that's another great question so he
asked is there a plan to support deep
learning like tensorflow or piano or
something
so I mean sight so if I could learn I
said all the great things about it the
one thing that it doesn't have is a you
know artificial neural that's even
though it's set you know there is a
model technically that's called that but
it doesn't do what you think it does and
so in order to do deep learning you have
to kind of switch over to tensorflow or
or theano or something like that so one
kind of interesting thing is that with
things like carrots you know we're
starting to move to a place where there
are API is for deep learning that are
similar to the scikit-learn API and I
think actually carrots deliberately used
the scikit-learn you know API as a
framework because that's what we're all
used to now and so I think it's possible
but if you have any ideas I think we
should talk about it you should
definitely help us implement that into
our API or we can just brainstorm about
how that would how that would work it
ends up being you know how you kind of
hook it into a base class and so we
could we could think about that it's
another good question thank you yes
that's an excellent question - the
question is you know how well do the
yellow-brick visualizers work on large
large amounts of data so not just kind
of high dimensional data big this way
but big this way you know so instance
wise and that is definitely a problem
and there are some of the visualizers
that will probably you know fail to
perform very well on large amounts of
data I'm thinking of for like the
parallel coordinates visualizer
which has to plot each instance as a
line segment of the connected line
segment I you know if you have a lot of
data points that's going to be going for
a while so I think that's a great great
question I think the answer is to use
some kind of sampling technique but we
haven't kind of solved that yet but I
think that that would definitely help to
be able to support you know large
datasets and yeah I'd love to talk about
if you have any ideas for for like a
smart way to do sampling you know that
or you know something like zoom and
filter where it's like kind of showing
you know where instead of each line
being an instance having each line be be
like a group of instances and then you
could zoom in or zoom out or something
like that to show different levels of
details you don't have to plot
everything in the first half yes
you know so he asked are there any ideas
for decision trees or sambal trees so
that's a great question
we actually have an open issue so
somebody asked somebody asked that
question on github in our issues and
made a suggestion of something we can
use actually I think it might have been
andreas möller the the scikit-learn guy
he's like one of the core contributors I
think we were just talking to him about
this and you know there there are some
challenges with the plotting you know
how to Ted a render the plot but I would
maybe check out that issue you can like
just do a text search in the issues and
see if you can find the one on decision
trees and feel free to weigh and if you
have any ideas or suggestions for how
yeah I think that would be enormous ly
helpful in you know you know if you're
using something like Java Script is sort
of like just JavaScript it but in Python
it's a little less you know less obvious
with with math hotline but I think it's
a really good question I think that
would really help you know it's
something a little bit like what I'm
dealing with now with the the dendogram
visualizer it's a little bit easier
though because you know you sort of you
know you know what the the constraints
are going to be ahead of time yeah
great question so you asked why are we
using MATLAB instead of one of the fancy
visualization libraries that's out now
that that's a wrapper so part of it is
because we want to keep the dependencies
to a minimum because we actually would
like to see this be something that
people use in production and so if you
have to like install pandas and NLC k
and Seaborn and bouquet and altair and
you know all the things in order to to
get the to get your package up and
running you know we're worried that that
would you know dissuade people from from
implementing it in a you know production
grade work that's really the main thing
but you know mascot labs the new you
know they just did a version bump too
it's pretty slick you know they've got
they've got some really nice things in
there you can do you know more than ever
with math how live and I I know this is
an unfocused conference I'm not just
saying that because none focus is is
sponsoring this but but map highlight is
actually very powerful for Python
yes that is a very good question so you
asked what about 3d visualization so one
way to think of this is that you know
there are different ways to to visualize
dimensions and so I think on the I don't
know if anybody was here yesterday and
saw the Gapminder presentation the Hans
Rosling visualization of the health and
wealth of nations so you can visualize
dimensions using things like size like
you know the size of points the color
and so we have a new visualization that
I believe is in the version bump to the
the 0.40 version that's a scatter plot
you know so that it's a 2d plot but
color is the third dimension and so
that's one option so you can use things
you know you can use other visual
signifiers to Dement other dimensions
and so that's sort of what we're doing
now since that's load the low-hanging
fruit is to kind of use like the Rudd
the Hans Rosling approach to try to you
know exploit the fact that we can you
know as humans we can you can you can
use color and shapes and things like
that to distinguish other Dement or to
represent other dimensions so yes if
there's thoughts about interactive plots
so we would definitely like to be able
to do that we're mostly Python
programmers if there's any you know Java
Script people out there who are
interested in talking we have another
parallel project called cultivar that
does support kind of interactivity which
i think is enormous ly important
[Applause]
[Music]
you